con estas disputadas elecciones moscú ha
aprovechado para señalar lo que
considera probadas deficiencias en el
sistema electoral estadounidense pero
rusia no tenía fe ni en uno ni en otro
candidato en moscú existe ahora al menos
la sensación de que el comportamiento de
washington será más predecible con joe
biden en la casa blanca pese a que
verbalmente baiden ha sido mucho más
duro con vladimir putin un destacado
senador ruso alekséi guskov ha advertido
de que combaten rusia y eeuu entrarán en
la fase de intensa guerra fría el propio
presidente ruso vladimir putin dijo el
mes pasado que en los mensajes de joe
biden se detectaba un claro discurso
anti ruso los medios rusos preferían eso
si a donald trump pero lo cierto es que
durante el mandato de trump rusia se ha
visto repetidamente golpeada por nuevas
sanciones por sus acciones en el
extranjero no sólo desde el congreso
norteamericano sino también desde el
ejecutivo algunos políticos rusos ahora
esperan un recrudecimiento de las
sanciones y los vetos contra moscú así
que parece que el reinicio
de las relaciones con eeuu es el
reinicio que se intentó con el arranque
de la era obama va a ser esta vez
imposible